well joining me now is Graham Davies
he's a personal presentation coach
Tina's work with senior figures
preparing for sessions such as these and
this one Graham is it's kind of biathlon
isn't it for the two leaders because
they've got two different formats the
interview Jeremy Paxman but first a live
audience so how do you prepare for that
well it's a bio film with only two
presidential style contenders because of
Theresa Mays Pacific choice not to have
a head-to-head combative debate
effectively it's almost like that old
television program flabby ators where
instead of them going head-to-head in
direct combat they in fact have to go up
against proxies provided by the TV
company with this time five Muslim and
Jeremy Paxman taking the part of Scorpio
and wolf and also meeting the public and
it's Bhilai actors never working with
children and small animals politicians
working with real people a bit of a
tricky moment well there it has to be a
level of spontaneity whether you're
dealing with the public but on the other
hand though what they'll just have done
during the course of their preparation
process is prepared what I call golden
nuggets and their short sentences which
are clever concise and compelling
rephrasing of what they've already said
saying for the last three weeks but
hopefully not lapsing back to the tired
campaign cliche probably the resume of
the risk is for the audience reactions
as well we've heard all that the
reaction could be a groan and a moan and
they got to see if they can say it by
the way of saying something new but
without coming up with anything that's
totally new and unexpected now let's
just talk about the two leaders in their
performing styles
Misha's May and then ladies been
coaching her but she's certainly taken
the leaf out of your book saying keep on
repeating what you want to say yes you
can't repeat it so much that people get
tired of it certainly the linton crosby
view is that right about the time when
commentators and journalists are
starting to sneer at a particular slogan
that's around about the time when the
public is starting to absorb and receive
it but I think this time the public are
getting that much more sophisticated and
has to be very careful not to do that
there was an academic study which showed
that even by the standards of
morticians I think the average answer
the question is about 46% just under 1 &
2 she's done a 14% 31 in a it's not a
problem that she doesn't tend to answer
the question I think people like her
genuine stability people do dislike her
possible rigidity under pressure but one
thing you can't change our people's
innate personal characteristics under
pressure her great strength is a
stability i think that jeremy corbyn's
weakness is his lack of stability and
depression yeah I was going to ask you
about that because I mean Jeremy Corbyn
is a man he's been in politics a long
time but he's by and large been a rebel
and he tended to speak to friendly
audiences now he's meeting a wider
cross-section yes he is and he also has
to cope with the fact that he's largely
disassociated detached from the rest of
the parliamentary party so whether he
likes to be an individual presidential
candidate or not he's been thrust into
that position it's been a deliberate
ploy by the Tories who virtually
projected to resume as a rock star
Theresa May and her support the
Conservative Party because they wanted
to get Jeremy Corbyn LNT so they want to
expose him as an individual and how do
you rate his performance so far in this
campaign well she she his great strength
is also his great weakness he's very
transparent when he's under pain under
pressure you can see it on the other
hand when you see Theresa May she can
look a little bit concrete face to face
but I'd say it tends to suggest that if
she ever leaves politics she's got a
great career ahead in poker I mean what
we get is that Jeremy could win
sometimes
techne when he's asked about defense
matters just sounds a bit weary and fed
up whereas this is maize and it crosses
on that which one works better with the
problems I think people like to see
genuine emotions Jeremy Corbyn does feel
pain when he's cross-examined about his
rather uncomfortable past was perhaps
saying things about the IRA Theresa May
feels pain when she's actually
questioned about whether she cares
enough and so actually I think that the
exposure of genuine emotions it's
probably a big good thing for both of
them now what about the the giveaways
not so much what they say about how they
say it their body language what have you
observed well we there is a gap between
sometimes that their verbal indicators
and their physical indicators what they
both tend to do slightly is to have what
I call precursor phrases jeremy corbyn's
managed to get away from them in the
last few weeks but what's a reason men
tend to do is that she uses a precursor
phrase if I could say that myself just
before she says something significant
her favorite is let me be absolutely
clear about that which gives a two extra
seconds of thought before she comes out
with a precise wording of something more
significant but on balance people seem
to find her quite a chilly finger which
may be good in choosing a prime minister
whereas they find Gary covering quite
sort of cozy about before well I think
that of course remember that the issues
have focused very carefully and very
precisely on this particular general
election to who's going to be the best
regular negotiator a warm cuddly jolly
upbeat dinner party guests may not be
the best person to get the best deal for
us from Brussels and I think probably
suits the Tories okay Graham thank you
very much the great analysis there Adam